the US Navy made it clear they wanted
everyone to see what they said were
Iranian weapons meant for houthi
fighters in Yemen and seized from the
stateless Dao they now say they've taken
the more than one million rounds of
ammunition found on it and sent it to
Ukraine the White House and state
department repeatedly pressed on whether
they have the legal right to do that the
secretary of defense is authorized with
the concurrence of the Secretary of
State to make available to the
government of Ukraine weapons and other
defense articles from the United States
and other sources this obviously is one
of those other sources under U.S law but
some are questioning if this violates
U.N agreements or international law
let's just put into this way given the
fact that the houthis are not
technically a state there is a a
rightful case to be made for the
confiscation of these weapons
the US has also seized thousands of
Iranian guns almost 200 rocket launchers
and dozens of guided missiles it's not
confirmed but those are likely headed to
Ukraine soon
the Pentagon says it still has about
five billion dollars it can use to send
weapons to Ukraine but U.S President Joe
Biden is asking Congress for 24 billion
the majority of people in Congress say
they want to see that age sent but it
could come down to just one job who
becomes the Speaker of the House of
Representatives one of the candidates so
far Jim Jordan says he is against any
additional Aid and he control he would
control what bills go to the floor the
other Representative Steve scalise says
he is in favor of more Aid to Ukraine so
you can imagine capitals all over the
world are going to be watching to see
who wins the speaker's gavel Patty
culhane Al Jazeera Washington
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera